[Music]
under compute engine in the Google cloud
platform console go to the VM instances
page and click create instance most of
the fields here will be pre-populated in
order to speed up the creation process
but you're welcome to adjust anything to
suit your needs
for now all you'll need to do is add a
name and in the boot disk section click
Change to begin configuring your boot
disk the first tab is the OS images tab
here you should choose Debian 9 and then
click select in the firewall section
click allow HTTP traffic click create to
create your instance you can check the
status on the VM instances page once
ready your instance will be listed here
with a green status icon after seeing
that icon next to your instance you're
ready to connect to open the terminal
directly to the instance you've just
created click the SSH button this will
open a new window and connect
congratulations
you now have a terminal window for
executing shell commands and interacting
directly with your Linux instance make
sure you delete any instances you don't
want to pay for after this QuickStart
[Music]